wondering about the medical earlier ASCVD risk estimator. So what that is, is that is
risk estimator for cardiovascular disease. Are you familiar with it? Yes, I'm familiar with it.
It's a, um, you put it in your parameters of your cholesterol and I don't know some different blood
parameters, your age and your weight and your blood pressure and such, and it gives you a risk
factor. Is that, um, uh, what's your thoughts about it? Taking on the risk factors of the
encounter appears that I might be very high risk. I'm working to make lifestyle changes. I welcome
any info. So for cardiovascular disease, there's, um, uh, there's a lot more than just the risk factors
that are in this little online questionnaire that you could fill out. So, um, is, is cholesterol
a factor in cardiovascular disease? Well, yes, if cholesterol is extremely high, um, it can be a
factor. What's a greater factor in my blood work than cholesterol that they don't even ask in this?
I don't think they ask it. That's triglycerides. They don't ask for triglycerides and triglycerides
is really your number one cardiovascular risk blood profile that you get in a, in a normal,
not in-depth, but in normal blood workup. Now, you can do an in-depth cardiovascular blood
workup where you're testing for, like, oxidative, um, lipid particles, um, that, um, that, uh, can be,
can show increased risk for cardiovascular things. Um, but when you, uh, get down to the most, uh,
common sources that are causes of cardiovascular risk, you're looking at H. Pylora, you're looking
at heavy metals, you're looking at Lyme disease, you're looking at, um, other toxins. So, working on
detoxification, working on dealing with H. Pylora, even if you don't have other signs of H. Pylora,
treated as if you have H. Pylora and, and getting your blood pressure down if you do have high
blood pressure because that could be a risk for, or cardiovascular disorders. I do have a whole series
on cardiovascular disorders in my blog post because I actually did an entire course of cardiovascular
number of years back. Um, and, um, there's other blood factors that you can take to, to measure
cardiovascular risk like interlucid six is a good one test to measure cardiovascular risk.
Though I know most standard medical doctors are really going to just look at cholesterol, H. Pylora,
LDL cholesterol, as you're made cardiovascular risk factors and then they're going to put person
as elevated cholesterol on a lipitor type product that's going to lower your cholesterol and then
you think that you have a lower cardiovascular risk and if you did a, um, online risk estimator
like this, it would show that you're in a lower risk factor, but you're really not. People that
lower their cholesterol artificially with, uh, statin drug doesn't actually lower their cardiovascular
disease risk because you're basically just artificially lowering cholesterol, because cholesterol
is not the culprit in cardiovascular disease. It's damaged to the arterial walls sometimes by
elevating almost 60 levels. Sometimes like I said, by, um, H. Pylora or Lyme disease or heavy metal
toxicity that's affecting the endothelial, because that's the inner lining of the vessels when you
have damaged endothelial cells, then that's what cholesterol can plaque on even below cholesterol will
still plaque on that. So do I give much credence to this risk estimator? No, because it's really not
taking into fact the real causes of cardiovascular disease and, um, uh, and dealing with those. So, um,
we'll discuss it further with you specifically. I'll gladly do that.